مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه مستمره
وفي عناوينها
اخراج احياء في درنه بعد سته اياما على
كارثه السيول والصحه العالميه تقدر عدد
المفقودين بتسعه الاف فرق الاغاثه تتجه
الى عزل مناطق في درنه واخلاء اخرى ونقيب
الاطباء يحذر في تصريحات للجزيره من
احتمال الوصول الى مرحله الوباء بسبب
انتشار الجثث
وفي المغرب السلطات تعلن تمكنها من فتح
جميع الطرق الرئيسيه في اقليم تارودانت
فرق الانقاذ توسع عملياتها في الاماكن
المعزوله باقليم الحوز وبدء تفعيل خطط دعم
و ايواء المتضررين
المعارك العنيفه تتجدد وسط الخرطوم قصف
واشتباكات في محيط القياده العامه وقرب
سلاح المهندسين الجيش يسلم صليب الاحمر 30
طفلا كانوا يقاتلون مع قوه الدعم السريع
ووزير الصحه يقول للجزيره ان كل
المستشفيات الرئيسيه في الخرطوم ودافور
خرجت عن الخدمه
نبدا من تداعيات السيول في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
بينما تحصي درنا الليبيه خسائرها بعد
الكارثه التي المت بها جراء السيول تتواصل
جهود البحث عن الاف المفقودين واغاثه
المتضررين واعلن وزير الصحه في الحكومه
المكلفه من البرلمان عثمان عبد الجليل
ارتفاع عدد الضحيه في مناطق شرق ليبيا الى
ثلاثه الاف ومئتين 252 قتيلا
ومع تصاعد اعداد القتلى والمفقودين ارتفعت
وتيره المناشدات من داخل درنه والمناطق
الاخرى طلبا لمزيد من فرق لانقاذ والاليات
والمعدات والخدمات
وقد تداول نشطاء على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطعا مصورا لاخراج عائله من
تحت انقاد منزل هدمته السيول في مدينه
درنه وتظهر صور مشاركه فرق اغاثه دوليه
ومتطوعين ليبيين في عمليه الانقاذ عسكريه
معنا من دارنا مراسله الجزيره تامر
الصمادي ومن طرابلس مراسل الجزيره احمد
خليفه ونبدا مع تامر الصمادي من درنه يعني
اخر المعلومات حول عمليات الاغاثه
ومحاولات الانقاذ خصوصا تلك التي كللت
بانقاذ احياء من تحت الانقاذ الى اي مدى
هذه الحالات تبقي الامل بوجود احياء تحت
انقراض المنازل
الان بالفعل حسن هذه الحالات التي يتم
العثور عليها وهي على قيد الحياه تبعث
الامل لكنه يبقى املا ضئيلا في ظل مرور
وقت طويل وفقا للسلطات الصحيه العامله في
المدينه وتحديدا الفرق الاغاثيه فرق
الانقاذ الحالات التي يتم العثور عليها
وهي على قيد الحياه هي حالات قليله جدا
بمقارنه بالاعداد الكبيره والهائله نتحدث
عن الاف البشر الذين ما زالوا عالقين تحت
الانقاض والمفقودين ايضا في غمار البحر
الماساه كبيره حسن وكبيره جدا لكل ما
توغلنا في هذه المدينه الحزينه المثقله
بالوجع المتقله بالهموم نكتشف كل مره هول
الصدمه وهول الفاجعه الكبيره والمحققه
اليوم تنقلنا بين عدد من الاحياء التي
تضررت الى حد كبير لا سيما في منطقه وادي
درنه هذه المنطقه التي طالها ما طالها من
دمار كبير ويعني يعني انقاض في كل مكان
حيثما وليت وجهك حسن هنالك انقاض هنالك
ركام هنالك
الكثير من العالقين تحت الانقاض اليوم
وصلنا الى عدد من المباني التي وفقا
لشهادات شهود العيان لازال تحتها الكثير
من العالقين ولم تصلها فرق الانقاذ حتى
هذه اللحظه هنالك جهود حقيقيه تبذل
بالنسبه للفرقه المحليه والعربيه والدوليه
التي هرعت الى عين المكان لكن هذه الفرق
تبقى قليله واعدادها ايضا قليله مقارنه
بحجم الكارثه بحجم
الماساه الحديث حتى هذه اللحظه عن عشره
الاف مفقود وفقا لعديد المنظمات الاغاثيه
المحليه والدوليه التي تتواجد في هذا
المكان هنالك شكوى متكرره من نقص
المعدات المتخصصه الخاصه بمثل هذه الاحداث
غير المحوده وغير المسبوقه ولذلك تتصاعد
المناشدات المحليه هنا
لاسيما على لسان العديد من المسؤولين في
المدينه بضروره تكثيف الجهود وارسال
المزيد من فرق الاغاثه المتخصصه في مثل
هكذا كوارث لم يسبق لهذه المدينه ولي
ليبيا عموما ان وقعت من قبل الماساه كبيره
وفيما يخص الحديث عن الارقام الارقام تبقى
متضاربه بينما يتحدث او تتحدث جهات حكوميه
عن ثلاثه الاف قتيل حتى هذه اللحظه هنالك
من يتحدث عن 5000 ويرتفع الرقم الى 7000
وهذا ربما عائد الى ان كل منظمه او جهه
تقوم بدفن الجثث التي تعثر عليها في مقبره
منفصله ولذلك حتى هذه اللحظه وفقا للعديد
من المسؤولين يصعد بشكل دقيق تحديد
الارقام الخاصه باعداد القتلى الحديث عن
مقابر جماعيه بدات تنتشر على اطراف
المدينه في ضواحي المدينه اليوم هنالك
حديث لمنظمه الصحه العالميه يشير الى وجود
اكثر من 1000 قبر مجهول في
المدينه قبر جماعي عفوا قبر جماعي في
المدينه وفي ضواحي المدينه وهنالك تحذيرات
من ان هذه القبور الجماعيه من شانها ان
تحقق كارثه في مقبل الايام فيما يخص
الكارثه او التخوفات من وقوع كارثه بيئيه
او وباء هنالك تخوفات كثيره بدات يعني
تظهر بشكل واضح على لسان العديد من
المسؤولين وهو ما دفع السلطات يوم امس
واليوم للحديث عن
الايام المقبله ستشهد عزل كثير من المناطق
وهي المناطق الاكثر تضررا بالاضافه الى
اخلاء ربما لعدد كبير من مناطق المدينه
شكرا لتامر صمادي من درنه شكرا جزيلا لك
وبالانتقال الى احمد خليفه في طرابلس امام
هذه الصوره التي رسمها لنا تامر في درنه
ما هي الاجراءات المتخذه من قبل السلطات
في طرابلس وطبيعه التواصل والتنسيق مع
القوه والمسؤولين في في الشرق
وتاكيدا لما ذكره الزميل تامر صمادي حسن
منذ قليل بالفعل انا ما زلت داخل رئاسه
مقر رئاسه مجلس الوزراء هنا في العاصمه
طرابلس منذ قليل حضرت جزءا من المؤتمر
الصحفي للفريق الحكومي الخاص بمتابعه هذه
الازمه وزير البيئه بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
اطلق تحذيرات واضحه من شرب المياه في
مدينه درنه وقال ان هناك كارثه بيئيه في
مدينه درنه ولا نضمن ان تكون المياه في
مدينه درنه الان صالحه للشرب ونصح بان بان
لا تشرب مياه الابار الجوفيه وخصوصا
بالنسبه للاطفال حذر بشده من هذه القضيه
وقال هناك تخوفات على الاطفال في مدينه
درنه ان يشربوا المياه الجوفيه في المدينه
من الابار الموجوده في المدينه وقال ننصح
بشرب المياه
بقى في زجاجات جاهزه فهي حاليا اضمن من
ايه مياه اخرى وقال لدينا فرق تعمل على
الارض واخذنا عينات منها التربه ومن
المياه لاجراء عمليات تحليل لها
واثبات ان كانت يعني نقيه ام ملوثه جراء
السيول والفيضانات ايضا وزير البيئه قال
ان التخوفات هذه منبعها ان السيول ضربت
بشده خطوط امدادات مياه الشرب وامدادات
مياه الصرف الصحي وهذا هو مصدر التخوفات
لديه في سياق متصل اخر يتعلق بعمل وزيره
العدل التي اعلنت ان هناك عدد كبير من
السجناء الذين
نقلوا قبل حدوث الاعسار على خلفيه
التخوفات
هذا من اعصار دانيال عندما اراجت الانباء
حول ان هذا الاعصار سيضرب المنطقه الشرقيه
وفي سياق الاجراءات الاحترازيه نقيه هؤلاء
السجناء الى مكان اخر ولم يصبهم شيء لكنها
قالت ان هناك سبعه من افراد الشرطه
القضائيه العاملين في
توفوا جراء السيول والفيضانات وقالت ان
الفرق التابعه للوزاره هناك الان تحصلت
على عينات للحمض النووي من 360 شخصا من
اهالي شكرا المنكوبين او المفقودين في هذه
السيول حسب خليفه حدثتنا من طرابلس
وتتركز عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه في مناطق
عديده من مدينه دارنا صعوبات لوجستيه جراء
تضرر الطرق والبنيه التحتيه نتعرف على
ملامح المشهد على الارض في هذا الارض
ملامح الفاجعه لم تكتمل بعد ذلك ابرز
انطباع مع انقضاء نحو اسبوع منذ كارثه
فيضان درنه دعا مدير عام المركز الوطني
لمكافحه الامراض حيدر السائح الى تقسيم
المدينه الى ثلاث مناطق متضرره وهشه وامنه
بهدف تحسين التعامل مع تداعيات الكارثه
واغاثه المتضررين
الشطر الغربي من المدينه هو الاكثر تضررا
وتتركز عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه في مناطق
عديده ابرزها وسط المدينه والمغار
والجبيله وبمنصور على الساحل الشرقي
للمدينه المنكوبه روت مصادر بالهلال
الاحمر للجزيره ان فرقه انقاذ من الغواصين
كشفت عن سيارات غارقه بعائلاتها جرفتها
مياه الفيضان ويوم الجمعه تقول المصادر
انما بين 500 الى 600 جثه انتشلت من البحر
في الشاطئ الغربي اغلبهم من الاطفال وتحت
البحر وفق المصادر عينها عمارات بالكامل
جرفها الفيضان يقول رئيس هيئه البحث
والتعرف على المفقودين للجزيره انه قد
انتشرت جثه كانت على مسافه 120 مترا داخل
البحر تشكو فرق الانقاذ من معوقات منها
صعوبه الحركه بسبب اكوام الوحل التي طمرت
بنايات بكاملها ومن صعوبه حركه الافراد
والمعدات بسبب تلك الاوحال الزلقه ويشكون
ايضا من قله مواد التعقيم بالنظر لاعداد
الجثث الهائله
كان نائب رئيس المجلس المحلي بدرنه قد صرح
للجزيره بشان احتمالات اخلاء كلي او جزئي
للسكان بالتحديد توقع اخلاء حي الجبيله
والمغار وما تبقى من سكان وسط المدينه
مؤكدا نزوح اعداد كبيره باتجاه مناطق باب
تبرق والفتائح والساحل الشرقي وغيرها في
نفس السياق تحدثت منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
نزوح نحو 35 الف شخص جراء الكارثه
[موسيقى]
انضم الينا الان بشير عمر المتحدث باسم
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر في ليبيا
سيد بشير مرحبا بك هلا ان نعرف ما لديكم
من معلومات اولا ان كان هناك حصيله بالطبع
حصيله مؤقته ولكن الى اين وصلت الحصيله
حتى اللحظه
شكرا جزيلا لقناه الجزيره على افسح هذا
المساحه للحديث عن اخر
فيما فيما يتعلق بالفيضان الذي ضرب
المناطق الشرقيه من البلد طبعا هناك
الكثير من التكهنات حول عدد الارقام او
عدد الضحايا والاشخاص الجرحى والنازحين
لكن الارقام طبعا هي بالالاف لكن لدينا
الرقم بالضبط لكن
تتواصل عمليه الانفاق
الاشخاص الذبحه وايضا الاشخاص الذين قضوا
تحت يعني تحت الطين والانقاذ وانقاذ
المباني فالارقام طبعا الرقم مرشح للزياده
لكن في الوقت الحالي ليس لدينا ارقام
ارقام محدده ونحن ان تكتمل عمليه الانقاذ
للاشخاص ان يكون لديها الرقم النهائي تكون
الارقام كبيره جدا لكن لا نستطيع التكهن
حقيقه في الوقت الرهان بالارقام النهائيه
والدقيقه فبنسالكم عن العمل الذي تقومون
به
كصليب احمر والتحديات او الصعوبات التي
تواجهونها بعد مرور عده ايام على كارثه
السيول
طبعا بخصوص انشطه اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر وما تقوم به في الوقت الحالي طبعا
منذ بدايه الازمه كنا ننسق بشكل يعني وثيق
جدا مع جمعيه الهلال الاحمر اليمني عفوا
جميع الهلال الاحمر الليبي والتي قامت
يعني ارسال المئات من الاشخاص المتطوعين
الى الميدان بدعم من اللجنه الدوليه لاصلي
بالاحمر قمنا بتقديم اكثر من الف اكياس
جثث للسلطات الليبيه وايضا لجمعيه الاحمر
الليبي قمنا بتزويد الجمعيه باجهزه
اتصالات وخصوصا عند بدايه هذه الكارثه
عندما كان هنالك وصول محدود لخدمات الهاتف
النقال والانترنت قمنا ايضا بتزويد
الجمعيه الهلال الاحمر بسيارات رباعيه
الدفع وايضا الان نقوم بتحضير الشحنه
انسانيه كبيره تكفي من المواد الغذائيه
تكفي اكثر من سته الف اسره من المناطق
المت ايضا قمنا بامداد السلطات والجمعيات
الهلال الاحمر بالمواد الطبيه والايوائيه
والمواد الغذائيه حتى هذه اللحظه لكن
اللجنه الدوليه الصليب الاحمر يعني دائما
نعرب عن استعدادتنا استعدادنا لمواصله هذا
الدعم الانساني للمناطق المنكوبه في الشرق
الليبي
على المستوى الصحي على المستوى الاغاثه
ما هي التحديات التي تواجهونها حاليا اين
هي المشاكل في عمل اركان الصليب الاحمر او
الهلال الاحمر او حتى منظمات اغاثيه اخرى
وطبيه
طبعا الصعوبات التي واجهتنا يمكن مواجهه
كل القطاع الانساني في ليبيا وايضا حتى
السلطات نفسها اولا تهدم او يعني الخراب
الذي طال قطاع البنى التحتيه في المناطق
المنكوبه وخصوصا في مدينه دارنا الجسور
تدمرت بسبب قوه اندفاع المياه في هذه
المناطق بسبب انهيار السدان في منطقه
دارنا بالتالي تقطعت اوصال هذه المدينه عن
المناطق الاخرى وصعب وذلك صعب وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى هذه المنطقه ايضا
غياب شبكه او انقطاع تغطيه الشبكه الهاتف
وايضا الانترنت عقد عمل الفرق الانقاذ
والفرق الطبيه وعمل المنظمات الانسانيه
طبعا فداحه الكارثه بحيث ان حيث انا نحن
كقطاع انساني يعني والدوله الليبيه نفسها
لم تكن تتوقع هذه الكارثه التي لم تحصل
العقود في في ليبيا بحيث لم يكن هناك شخص
يعني قادر على التنبؤ بهذه الكارثه التي
هي يعني فوق قدرات السلطات المحليه وايضا
قدرات المؤسسات يعني المؤسسات والمنظمات
الدوليه الموجوده في ليبيا فكانت بمثابه
صدمه لكل هذه السلطات والمنظمات وبالتالي
يعني حجم الكارثه
اوقف يعني الجميع في حيره ما الذي يمكن
عمله لكننا بدانا بالعمليه الانسانيه
والعمليه الانسانيه على قدم وساق وتجري
الان بشكل افضل مما كان عليه بالبدايه
يعني وكانك تلمح او تشير هنا الى انه
لم تواجهكم على مدى عملكم في العقود
الماضيه لم تواجهكم كارثه بهذا المستوى
يعني على الاقل في في في ليبيا طبعا نحن
اكلنا يعني كنا في ليبيا صحيح ان ليبيا
تمر بتبعات النزاع المسلح لكن لم نكن
نتوقع هذه الكارثه لم يكن في مخازن
المنظمات الانسانيه الادويه الكافيه
والمواد الغذائيه الكافيه وبالتالي عندما
حصلت هذه الكارثه تطلب ذلك بعض الوقت لجلب
هذه المساعدات الى الى داخل البلد
شكرا جزيلا لك بشير عمر المتحدث باسم
اللجنه الدوليه ليصلي بالاحمر في ليبيا
واقل النائب العام الليبي الصديق الصور
للجزيره انه تم وضعه خطه بالتعاون مع
وزارتي الداخليه والصحه لتحديد جثث
الضحايا والتعرف على هوياتهم
كان وضع خطه
العمل حيث تم تكليف لجنه من الاستدلال من
وزاره الداخليه
مكتب النائب العام
تقوم بفتح محاضر
للمفقودين باثبات المفقودين هو ادراجهم
بحي العمليه البحث والتحرك
معنى من دارنا يوسف
باشكورت فنيه البحث والانقاذ في فريق
الانقاذ التابع لهيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه افاد مرحبا بك سيد يوسف المعروف
ان ان لكم افاد كان لكم
دور كبير في عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
اثناء زلزال تركيا هل من اوجه شبه بينما
حصل في تركيا وكارثه السيول في درنه هذا
التشابه ربما ساعدكم في
اختصار الوقت بعمليات البحث والانقاذ
ك الكثير من
اننا كان هناك الكثير من الانهيارات في
المباني ان الامر كان خلفته هزه ارضيه
بالتالي تبعنا نفس الخطوات
والاجراءات المتبعه في حالات الهزل
الارضيه حاولنا ان
نقوم
بنجرى اجراءات مفصله بشكل كامل
وماذا عن موضوع الجثث التي كانت منتشره
اكان في الطرقات او تلك الجثث التي جرفتها
السيول الى البحر
جزء من واجبنا نحن نحاول ان نعثر على هذه
الجثث ونحاول ان نقوم بفتح الطرق ونحقوم
بجمع الجثث ورفعها من الطرقات وان تم
تسليمها الى مقرات الشرطه هم يقوموا
بجمعها هناك
وهذه
مستويات مهامنا في هذا السياق
ما هي مستوى
او ما هو مستوى المعدات التي
تمتلكونها والتي تعملون من خلالها على
محاوله انقاذ من يمكن انقاذه او رفع
الانقاض
مجموعه
انقاذ دوليه قمنا باحضار المعدات التي
نحتاجها ونحن نتعاون مع المجموعات الدوليه
الاخرى المجموعه الايطاليه مثلا ونحن
نستخدمه الهليكوبتر الخاصه بهم وايضا
نحاول ان نقوم باتخاذات باستخدامي
المعدات الاخرى التقليديه ايضا
اشرت الى الى وجود تنسيق كما فهمت منك
بينكم وبين فرق دوليه دوليه اخرى في اي
مجال تحديدا يتم هذا التنسيق
كنا اول فريق وصل الى هنا بالتالي قمنا
بوضعي مخيماتنا ومخيمات والخيم الخاصه
بالتنسيق وعندما وصلت الفرق الاخرى قمنا
باجراء تواصل معهم ونحن نقوم بايضا العملي
جميعا
ونقوم بالتواصل مع بعضنا البعض وليس لدينا
مشكله في هذا الامر اذا ما كان هنالك مثلا
حاجه لكلاب البحث والانقاذ او اي احتياجات
اخرى نحاول ان نقدم الدعم لبعضنا البعض
بالنظر الى تجربتكم السابقه في اثناء
زلزال تركيا
هل
تتوقعون وقتا او زمنا معينا
لانتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ
من الصعب الجزم في هذا الامر نحن نحاول ان
نقوم بمهامنا ونريد ان من الاوضاع ان
تتحسن بشكل
باسرع وقت ممكن وسنقوم بوسعنا
لمساعدتهم هل ما زالت هناك توقعات بوجود
احياء ربما تحت الانقاض
لكن بمرور الوقت اعتقد ان عدد الناجين
سيقل نعم طيب
فضلا عن عن رسل انقاذ ومحاوله الانقاذ هل
لديكم دور في مساله الاغاثه والايواء ايضا
قمنا باحضار الف ومئتين خيمه
معنا من اجل نصب هذه الخيام
والناس الذين يحتاجون الى ماوى كما قلت
1200 ما سيتم توزيعها على من يحتاجها يوسف
باشكورت فني البحث والانقاذ في فريق
الانقاذ التابع لهيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه افاد شكرا جزيلا لك من درنا
قلل المتحدث باسم جهاز الاسعاف والطوارئ
في ليبيا اسامه علي ان اولويات
المرحله الراهنه تتركز على الاسراع في حصر
العدد الفعلي للضحايا والمفقودين
ما يحتاج الاسراع في هو حصر عدد الضحايا
الفعلي او الرقم الفعلي لعدد الضحايا
فهناك الكثير من المكالمات عن مفقودين
لم يسالون عنهم ايضا حصر الجنسيات التي
توفيت بشكل جيد
حتى نتمكن من ايفاء كافه الشروط في هذا
المجال لا تنسى ان هناك من مصريين الجنسيه
واخواننا في مصر من سوريا من السودان من
فيجب اعاده يجب النظر في هذه النقطه ايضا
وليس النظر في الضحايا بشكل عشوائي فقط
وتدور لنا ناشطون صورا تظهر محاولات فريق
اغاثه اسباني التواصل مع احد العالقين تحت
الركان في مدينه درنه شرق ليبيا وتظهر
الصور صعوبات التي يواجهها فريق الانقاذ
ومحاولات البحث عن اي اشارات لمعرفه مكانه
تحت الامر
يا عباد الله لو تسمع فيا حر في ايدك بس
يا عبد الله
حرك ايدك بس خربش
[موسيقى]
انا طارق الخراز المتحدث باسمي وزاره
الداخليه في الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
مرحبا بك سيد طارق
هل من تحديثات جديده في الارقام ارقام
الضحايا ارقام المفقودين وايضا
معلومات اخرى حول مستجدات ما يحصل
نعم ابدا بكلامي بكل الشكر للمجتمع الدولي
ولكل الدول التي ساهمت في الوصول الى
مدينه قرنه واستعجال عمليات الانقاذ
باستخراج هم على قيد الاحياء او اخراج من
انتقل الى رحمه الله سواء كان في اعماق
البحر او في الاماكن التي تحت الاتربه
وتحت الركام في مدينه درنه بما يعرف بالخط
الوفي اما فيما يتعلق بسؤاليك يعني تعتبر
الامور في مدينه درنه احسن تنظيما الى
الان
والعمل الذي تعمل به الغرفه مما اشراف
ايضا السيد النائب العام الذي كان يوم امس
سيجتمع كل الدوائر التي تابعه للجيش
الليبي وتابعه للقوات الامنيه وعلى ان
تكون من مهام هذه اللجنه فتح تحقيقات فيما
يتعلق
بصدرنا وكذلك الى حصر المفق
الوفيات بشكل رسمي ويتم اعلن عليها بشكل
رسمي هي حقيقه كل يوم في الارقام في عمليه
تجديد استخراج من الجثث هناك سعوديين هناك
اشخاص كان مبلغ عنهم وفيات ووجدوا على قيد
الحياه هناك نازحين بكثره خارج مدينه
دمائيه صعبت في الوقت الحالي في هذه
الظروف ان تحصر كلها هؤلاء ولكن هناك خطه
مستقبليه فورا للانتهاء من العمليات داخل
مدينه درنا على ان يكون هناك احصاء شامل
وكامل وتكون هناك ارقام حقيقيه عن الوفيات
وعند من هم على قيد الحياه
ونجوا من هذه الكارثه في مدينه هل هناك
مدى زمني لهذه الخطه التي اشرت اليها
نعم هو العمل الان مستمر حتى لا تنتقل
من الاوبئه والامراض داخل مدينه درنه وهذا
الذي جعل القوات الجيش وكذلك الشرطه تعلن
عن
اكثر ضبط واكثر لشده في التنظيم ومنع دخول
المواطنين الى الملا المناطق خاصه التي هي
تضررت بشكل مباشر جراء هذه اقل من
الجراءات وهذه الانهار التي حلت على مدينه
دارنا حتى لا تكون هناك الامراض معديه حتى
لا تسجل امراض اخرى يعني من اولوياتنا نحن
كجهاز شرطه المحافظه على الامن الصحي داخل
مدينه درنه ومحافظه على المواطنين اهل
مدينه برما وترتيب الامور داخل مدينه هل
سيتم اخلاء مدينه درنه بالكامل كما اشيع
مؤخرا
لا اعتقد اننا سن الخليج كل اهل مدينه
درنا من مناطقهم التي تضرر داخل مدينه
برلما يعرف يوصل البلاد والمنطقه القديمه
هي المناطق التي تضررت الضرر المباشر
ونسبه الدمار فيها 100% حددت النطاقها وكم
باغلاقها بدوريات امنيه داخل مدينه دارنا
لمنع كل من ليس له علاقه بالعمل داخلها
البعثات او الفرق الانقراض الدوليه
والمحليه وكذلك من هم ملطون بالعمل سواء
كان الصليب الاحمر وغيره من سيارات
الاسعاف ودوائر التابعه لوزاره الصحه في
مدينه برنه ان تدخل وان تكون باجراءات
اخرى تدمير وقائيه احترازيه حتى لسلمتهم
وصحتهم داخل المدينه
يعني
المناطق البعيده نسبيا عن عن قلب المدينه
ولم يطلها التدمير
هذه المناطق لن يتم اخلائها في دارنا
صحيح صحيح العمل الان مستمر حتى في هذه
المناطق
اجهزه الخدمات العامه تمر بها بشكل مباشر
في كل ساعه وفي الوقت
بفحص الاماكن وفتح مراكز صحيه على تتبعها
واذا كان هناك حالات
شكوى من عدم وجود تنسيق على الارض
وبالتالي هذا الامر يؤثر سلبا في عمليات
البحث والانقاذ والاغاثه ايضا
صحيح ان اكيد يعني ان كل حرب وكل كوارث
تحدث في اي دوله في العالم لابد ان تجب
الفوضى وان تكون الفوضى هي السائده في اول
ايامها نحن علينا في اول يومين من تلك
الفوضى لاسباب قد تدخل فيها العاطفه وتدخل
فيها الجرح الكبير التي مر فيه مدينه درنه
ولكن الان يعني اصبح الامر اكثر ترتيبا
وتنسيقا هناك فرقه من الجيش ومن الشرطه
تعمل حتى مع التنسيق مع فرق الانقاذ داخل
مدينه درنه وتم توزيع مهامها شرقا وغربا
وكذلك
داخل مدينه سيد طارق باختصار شديد كيف يتم
التعامل مع موضوع الجثث والتعرف عليها قبل
دفنها باختصار
صحيح هي صعبنا الان ان تتعرف عليها
المباشر او بهوياتها لان المعالم تغيرت في
مئه في المئه خاصه
يعني هناك اجراءات تابعه للسلطه القضائيه
باخذ عينات
مباشره في هذا
شكرا لك طارق الخرازه المتحدث باسم وزاره
الداخليه في الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان
حدثتنا من درنا
قال نقيب الاطباء في ليبيا محمد الغوج ان
هناك مخاوف من مرحله ثانيه قد تصل حتى
انتشار الوباء بسبب تحلل الجثث التي لا
تزال تحت الانقاض او منتشره في مدينه درنه
واكد الغوج في مقابلات مع الجزيره ان لجنه
الازمه في وزاره الصحه تكثف جهودها لتقديم
الرعايه الصحيه للمتضررين وان الاولويه
تتمثل في انتشال الجثث كما اكد الحاجه
الملحه الى وجود فرق للدعم النفسي
من المرحله الثانيه اتمنى من وزاره الصحه
ومؤسسات الدوليه لدعم هذا الموضوع في قصه
انه قد نصل الى الى قدر الله الى موضوع
الوباء النتيجه الاتحاد
اعطاكم الله الحفاظ الحيوانات لانها تعتبر
درنه من من المدن المنتجه لهذه الاغلبيه
هذه الحيوانات
قضتنا في هذا الاثار ايضا زي ما قلت
لحضرتك موضوع الدعم النفسي اعتقد حيكون
تحدي كبير للسلطات الصحيه لوزاره الصحه
هذا هو حزرت الامم المتحده من مغبه اعتماد
سكان مدينه درنه في ليبيا على مصادر
المياه الطبيعيه في المدينه مؤكده ان
التلوث قد وصل الى هذه المصادر يتزامن هذا
التحذير مع مناشده اطلقتها السلطات
الليبيه لسكان المناطق المتضرره بضروره
استخدام المياه المعلبه فقط وكانت السلطات
قد سجلت عشرات الاصابات بالتسمم في دارنا
[موسيقى]
كارثه تولد اخرى في ليبيا بعد الفاجعه لا
مياها صالحه للشرب والمياه الجوفيه ملوثه
بحسب الامم المتحده تحذيرات مستمره تطلقها
السلطات المحليه ايضا من خطوره المياه
السطحيه والجوفيه في درنه بحسب وزاره
البيئه حيث سجلت السلطات قرابه 150 حاله
تسمم بالفعل نتيجه تحلل الجثث وتضرر شبكات
الصرف الصحي واختلاط المياه بالسيول وما
تحمله من نفايات واوحال وملوثات وما يزيد
من سوء الوضع المائي ان شبكه المياه
الحكوميه مهترئه ولم تخضع لاي صيانه او
تجديد منذ سنوات
وخرجت المحطه البخاريه لتحليه مياه البحر
عن الخدمه فماذا يشرب حاليا سكان درنه
مختصرا مياه الشرب المعلبه هي المصدر
الوحيد الامن للسكان لكن فرق الانقاذ
والسلطات تواجه تحديات بايصال المياه اصلا
بسبب تقطع الطرق
قصه مدينه درنا تختصر مشكله المياه عامه
في البلاد يضاف اليها خصوصيه الفيضان
توسعترنا سكانيا وعمرانيا في العقود
الاخيره ما رفع من نسبه احتياجها للمياه
ومع غياب ترشيد في استخدام وصيانه الموارد
غزت الملوحه المياه الجوفيه في منطقه شيحه
وتضررت الابار التي كانت تغذي المنطقه
والتي غالبا ما يعمد السكان الى حفرها
اضافه لانخفاض في نسب المياه المتوفره وفق
الفصول بسبب السحب الجائر للمياه
تغيب الانهار عنها كليا وتشكل المياه
السطحيه الناتجه عن الامطار قرابه ثلاثه
في المئه من المياه المستخدمه تحبس في
صدور صناعيه كما تعتمد منطقه الجبل الاخضر
بشكل عام على ينابيع جبليه وهذا ما يجعل
المياه الجوفيه مصدر الارواء الاكبر بنسبه
97%
[موسيقى]
الى المغرب والمشهد بعد يوم ثامن على
كارثه الزلزال
[موسيقى]
مباشره الى عثمان اي فرح هو جوله مع
مراسلينا على الارض هناك عثمان
شكرا لك حسن اذا عمليات الانقاذ تستمر
وكذلك الجهود المبذوله لمساعده المتضررين
واليوم يوم السبت هو يوم عطله وبالتالي مع
كون الطرق اصبحت مفتوحه الان عدد السيارات
والقوافل شئت الذين
التي تذهب الى المناطق المتضرره اكبر
اليوم الناس استغلوا يوم العطله اليوم
ليذهبوا الى المناطق المنكوبه لتقديم
المساعده سواء بالسيارات او البعض
للمساعده بدراجاتهم الناريه كما شاهدنا في
مره سابقه مع المختار العملاوي في اقليم
الحوز للوصول الى المناطق النائيه
والمعزوله والامر لا يقتصر على المغاربه
من داخل المغرب فقط يعني
التقينا بفتيات مغربيات ممرضات جئنا من
دول اوروبيه ايضا بالمساعده
في علاج
المرضى وفي الاثناء طبعا بدا تفعيل
للادريجي
للمتضررين مع وجود صندوق خصص لمعالجه
اضرار الزلزال ومساعده المضاد المتضررين
وهذا الصندوق تبرع في شركه المدى التابعه
للعائله الملكيه بمليار درهم ما يعادل 100
مليون دولار وايضا تبرع البنك المركزي
بمبلغ مماثل وبلغت نسبه يعني المبلغ الذي
تم جمعه في هذا الصندوق حتى الان 6 مليار
درهم وهو ما يعادل 600 مليون دولار سنتحدث
عن ذلك بتفصيل اكثر لاحقا ربما مع عمر
الحاج الذي ينضم الينا من مراكش ولكن نبدا
معك ميساء الفطناسي في مراكش للحديث عن
تفعيل
الايواء التدريجي للاكثر تضررا في هذا
الزلزال
نعم عثمان بالفعل الحاجه الى الايواء ما
زالت متواصله هنا في مدينه مراكش وايضا في
بقيه الاقاليم والمدن التي ضربها الزلزال
الاخير قبل ثمانيه ايام نحن الان في
القاعه الرياضيه المغطاه بمدينه مراكش هذه
القاعه التي تحولت اليوم الى مركز لواء
عشرات المتضررين من الزلزال الاخير هموما
من سكان المدينه العتيقه الذين تضررت
منازلهم بشكل كبير جراء الزلزال الاخير
افتتح هذا المركز اليوم وبدا بايواء عدد
من هؤلاء السكان وما زالت عمليات الايواء
متواصله الى حين استكمال طاقه استيعاب هذا
المركز التي تبلغ حوالي 250 شخصا سنتعرف
على هذا المركز وعلى نشاطه والترتيبات
التجري له مع السيد عبد العزيز بوسعيد
او او نائب بلديه نائب رئيس
نتحدث معك عن هذا المركز كيف جرت
الترتيبات لهذا المركز والافتتاحه وان حيث
نعلم انها ما زالت تجري الى اليوم شكرا
جزيلا شكرا قناه الجزيره الاخباريه على
التفاعل ديالكم والمواكبه ديالكم من اول
يوم من بعد مدينه مراكش الاقاليم المجاوره
هو واحد من سبعه المراكز على مستوى
المدينه مراكش هذا المركز
والسكان المدينه العتيقه المتضررين واخا
هو كاين خارج المدينه العتيقه ولكن لسكان
المدينه العتيقه اللي هم اكبر عدد
المتضررين على مدينه مراكش كان في المدينه
العتيقه فالاحياء المجاوره والاحياء
الجديده على مستوى المدينه
قلتي الان التحقت به واحد تقريبا عندنا
فضاءات اخرى اكبر جائزيه
توفير المستلزمات الحياه فيما يخصنا الاكل
ولا الفيشه ولكن السلطه المحليه كذلك اللي
هي التوجيه المراكز بحكم المسؤوليه
ديالتها
هو منخرط المجتمع المدني الهلال الاحمر
المغربي اللي كتلاحظوا الان بانه العمل
ديالو فيما يخص
الاطباء النفسانيين
هنايا من الجانب النفسي ديالهم الانسان
ملي كيخرج من الزلزال شويه مصدوم هادشي
كله هو جاي تطبيق
تعليمات الساميه الملكيه الساميه اللي جات
في البلاغ الملكي هاد الناس بطبيعه الحال
غادي يقضي واحد الموت طويله الى حين اعاده
اعمار المدينه
[موسيقى]
على مستوى المدينه ولا على مستوى الاقاليم
هل هناك ربما مساعي الى مزيد
افتتاح ربما مراكز اخرى في ظل الحاجه
الملحه والمتواصله للاواء من قبل الناس
الذين ما زالوا لم يجدوا بديلا عن منازلهم
اكيد هناك مجموعه مراكز سبعه
المئوي دي كلها هي تتشتغل وكلها هي منظمه
بشكل محكم لا من ناحيه الاكل ولا من ناحيه
الافريشه ولا من ناحيه الطبيب ولا من
ناحيه السلامه ديال الناس اللي كاينين
فيها سبعه المئوي واذا احتاجنا اكثر
بامكاننا
عثمان هكذا هي جهود الايواء هنا في مدينه
مراكش الجميع هنا
يتكاثف والجميع يساهم في هذه الخدمه
لرفع قليل من الضرر على الناس الذين اصبحت
مساكنهم غير صالحه للسكن بفعل الزلزال
الاخير في انتظار الحلول الدائمه ربما لهم
باصلاح منازلهم والعوده للعيش فيها
نعم ويلعب دورا مهما ميساء في هذا الموضوع
الصندوق الذي خصص لدعم المتضررين عمر اذا
ما حدثتنا عنه وكانت التعليمات من الملك
وكان هو اول المتبرعين
هذا صحيح عثمان الصندوق المخصص للمتبرعين
او كما يطلق عليه هنا صندوق 126 صندوق اسس
على غرار صندوق كورونا الذي اسسته المملكه
خلال ازمه كورونا للدعم هذا الصندوق كما
الان المغاربه
التبرعات التي كانت وقت صندوق كورونا
والان الحديث عن سته مليارات درهم اي ما
يعادل اكثر من 600 الف مليون
دولار امريكي هذا على الاقل في التقديرات
الحاليه يفوق ربما احتياج المغرب الذي
قدمت دراسات ان كلفه انشاء كل منزل تتراوح
بين 9 و12 الف دولار اي ان اللي خمسين الف
اسره هذا الصندوق كما ذكرت ايضا كانت
المساهمه مساهمه الملك محمد السادس هي
الاكبر عبر مدى شركه مدى القابضه عن ملوكه
للعائله الحاكمه هنا بمليار دولار البنك
المركزي مليار دولار وايضا المكتب الشريف
في الفوسفات وهو المؤسسه الوطنيه للفوسفات
التي يشتهر من المغرب كان مليار مليار
درهم عذرا تصحيحا مليار درهم هذه الاموال
كما ذكرت ستستخدم لتتوظف لاعاده الايواء
واللي بناء المساكن وايضا
للمساعده الماليه التي ستقدم بمقدار 3000
دولار لكل اسره على ان يخصص بين تسعه كما
ذكرت الى 13 الف دولار
ببناء اعاده بناء المنازل المهدمه بشكل
كامل عمليات
المساعدات العينيه الاخرى التي تقدم
المتضررين تجري على قدم وساق بتنظيم
الاكبر
وبطلب من قبل السلطات للمواطنين بتركي هذه
المساعدات العينيه في المستودعات الخاصه
لمؤسسه محمد الخامس ومؤسسه محمد السادس
الخيريه التي تقوم بتوزيعها بشكل عادل على
كل الاقاليم الخمسه وليس فقط على اقليم
الحوز الذي يغلب تغلب عليه القوافل الاكثر
القاف
المنطقه كونه مركز الاجهزه اليوم ايضا كنا
في مركز التنسيق الخاص بعمليات الاغاثه
للفرق الاجنبيه بالتنسيق مع الفرق الوطنيه
المغربيه كانت هناك محاولات للوصول الى
بعض المناطق المعزوله عبر الحوامات
الهليكوبتر بعض هذه الرحلات لم تتكلم
بالنجاح نتيجه للرياح العكسيه كما قالنا
مرتادو هذه الرحله ولكنهم عاودوا في مرات
اخرى ايضا الحديث عن تسخير كل الموارد
والوسائل الخدميه من قبل السلطات اليوم
كان هناك مقطع فيديو يظهر ارسال اربع
طائرات درون مسيره لانجاد اربعه رعاق
كانوا قد تاهوا وتقطعت بهم مستوى بعد
اغلاق الطرق نتيجه انهيارات الصخريه هذه
الطائرات ساعدتهم في البدايه بعد ذلك
ارشدتهم الى الطريق الثاني
شكرا جزيلا عمر الحاج من مراكش وشكرا
للمساء الفطناسي التي كانت معنا اذن هذا
هو الوضع حسن وبالنسبه للصندوق المخصص
لدعم المتضررين فقد قررت الدوله ان تكون
المراكز او الفروع التابعه للخزينه العامه
مفتوحه طوال الاسبوع حتى في ايام العطل
للمساهمه فيه نعود ونتابع معك هذه التغطيه
نعود اليك في الدوحه شكرا لك عثمان اي فرح
من المغرب
ونواصل في نفس الموضوع حيث تواصل فرق
الاغاثه التابعه للدرجه الملكيه المغربيه
نقل المساعدات الانسانيه الى سكان القرى
النائيه المتضرره من الزلزال في جبال
الاطلس واقامت هذه الفرق جسرا جويا لنقل
الجرحى نحو المستشفيات الميدانيه مراسل
الجزيره شمال برا رافق احدى هذه الفرق
واعدت تقرير التالي
لحظات قليله امام فاطمه افشكو لتلقي نظره
خاطفه على مخطط رحلتها نحو القرى التي
تضررت بفعل الزلزال العنيف الذي طلب مناطق
شاسعه في جبال الاطلس
مهمتها اليوم نقلب مولدات كهربائيه لاهالي
القرى تحسبا لموسم الشتاء
بمجرد ان ارتفعت المروحيه بدات تساير
الاخاديد الملتويه طيار المروحيات يحسبون
الف حساب لمخاطر التحليق فوق الجبال
الشاهقه
عندما وصلنا لوجهتنا كان الرائد حكيم دويش
يعطي اوامره لفريق الاغاثه هؤلاء هم نخبه
القوات الخاصه لرجال الدرك متدربون على
عمليات الانقاذ المحفوفه بالمخاطر
المتقلبها الزلزال هي منطقه التضاريس
ومسالك وعره
كتواجد بمنطقه للارتفاع ديالها فوق 1830
متر عن سطح البحر بنك جبال وعره التضاريس
قابلنا سيده قرويه تناشد الفريق الطبي
مساعده امها المسنه ثم وصلت مروحيه ثانيه
تحمل جرحى ومصابنا سينقلون على وجه السرعه
الى مستشفى الميداني قريب مهمه
الفرد على النها
يه ان الجسر الجويه سيستمر ما دام اهالي
القرى النائيه في امس الحاجه للمساعدات
العاجله
يواصل العقيد ظلمات طارق رحلته مشيا على
الاقدام عبر المنعرجات والسفوح المنحدره
والممرات الصعبه
لهم المساعدات الصحيه ونشوفو المشاكل
الصحيه
والنفسيهم الادويه
وصلنا الى القريه التي ننشدها ما لمح
الصدمه باديه على وجوه نسوه الحي ذكريات
اللحظات الرهيبه التي تلت الزلزال لا تزال
عالقه في اذان الجميع
عاش هؤلاء حياه باكملها هنا حيث ولدوا
وحيث عاش اجدادهم لذا يفضلون البقاء في
مواطنهم في انتظار ان تعود الحياه كما
كانت وتعلو البسمه وجوه الناس من الواضح
ان عمليه اعاده تاهيل المناطق المنكوبه
سوف تستغرق زبلا طويلا لانه بمجرد ان تزول
ببصرك حول هذه الوديان والجبال المحيطه
بالمناطق التي تضررت بالشكل كبير ليتضح لك
بشكل جلي حجم الدمار والمعاناه وفي هذا
الخضم تسعى السلطات جاهده بطي صفحه وبدء
صفحه اخرى هاشمها
معنا من لندن ساره مديره شؤون الانسانيه
في منظمه اكشن ايد الدوليه مرحبا بك
السيده ساره الى اين وصلت
مساهماتكم مساهمه
في عمليات الاغاثه لضحايا ومتضررين زلزال
المغرب
شكرا على الاستضافه اذا اكشن ايدي كانت في
الميدان منذ الايام الاولى التي تلت الهزه
الارضيه نحن نعمل مع منظمات منظمات شراكه
محليه ونلتقي ونلبي بعض الاحتياجات
الاساسيه
وخاصه مساله الماء
ووصلنا بعد اسبوع كانت هنالك عوائل بعد
نزل الارضيه تعيش في العراق وتخشى من
العوده الى منازلها هو خاصه بالنسبه
للفتيات والنساء وكانوا في وضع خطير للغير
ذلك قدمنا له المساعده في هذا المجال
وهل تعتبرين ان ما قدم كاسن حتى الان
الاحتياجات كبيره واعتقد ان هذا الامر
عرضته التقارير المختلفه وكان هنالك ربما
امكانيه صعبه الامر صعوبه الوصول الى بعض
القرى البعيده نعرف ان هنالك قرى قد اختفت
بالكامل تهدمت بالكامل وكان هناك الكثير
من الاشخاص الذين خسروا حياتهم وهنالك
افتقار للاحتياجات الاساسيه الغذاء والماء
والماء وايضا بالنسبه للنساء مثلا
معدات النظافه الشخصيه والصابون التي
تمكنهم من تربيه احتياجاتهم في التنظيف
وايضا ادوات التعقيم هنالك حاجه كبيره لها
سكان المحليين يتوحدون
يجتمعون مع بعضهم البعض ويقدمون الدعم
لبعضهم البعض والكل يقدم ما باستطاعته لكن
الاحتياجات ببساطه كبيره لكي يتم تلبيتها
بدون اي جهود اغاثه اضافيه وايضا الدعم
طويل الامد للتعافي ونعرف انه لن ياخذ
ياما واسابيع بالاشهر اذا يعني كنت اود ان
اسالك ان كانت المنظمات الاهليه
والمدنيه تستطيع ان تنبي كل هذه المطالب
لكنك اجبت وقلت
انها هذه المطالب تفوق قدره هذه المنظمات
فيما يتعلق بالايواء هل لديكم دور بعمليات
الايواء ولو عن طريق الخيام
حاليا لا اعتقد ان السؤال يتعلق
بالامكانيات اعتقد ان
التركيز على السلطات والمنظمات المحليه
والحكومه المغربيه متمكنه بشكل كبير لكن
حجم الكارثه كبير جدا بحيث ان هنالك حاجه
لتكثيف الجهود وهذا امر طبيعي في اي بلد
قد يتاثر بنفس الطريقه التي تاثر بها
المغرب بالتالي ما نقوم به حاليا هو اننا
ننظر الى كيف بامكاننا ان نعمل بشكل افضل
مع الاخر من اجلي تكميلي الجهود المقدمه
وقد قمنا بتوزيع بعض المعدات الاغاثه مواد
الغذائيه
البطانيه
والامور اخرى ونحن الان ننظر الى مساله
امكانيه استكمال جهود التي تقوم بها
السلطات المحليه والم نظمات وخاصه فيما
يتعلق باحتياجاتي النساء والفتيات وهذه هي
احدى المجالات التي نمتلك خبره طويله في
العمل فيها في المغرب وفي دول اخرى شهدت
ازمات وكبرت طبيعيه
باختصار هل تاخذون بعين الاعتبار تحدي قرب
فصل الخريف وبالتالي البرد واحتمال سقوط
امطار
وبالتالي هذا يوجب ان نوحد جهودنا من اجل
ان نقدم الدعم للسكان المغاربه الذين
تاثروا بهذه الهزه الارضيه المروعه نعرف
ان الوقت ينفد علينا ان نزيد من جهود
الاغاثه من اجل ان نضمن ان من يحتاج هذه
المساعدات لن يكون في خطر البدء مثلا فصل
الشتاء او الخريف سارى المر من لندن
مديره شؤون الانسانيه في منظمه اكشن ايده
الدوليه شكرا جزيلا لك
وقال مسؤول الاعلام ببرنامج القضيه
العالميه للسودان محمد جمال للجزيره انما
يزيد على عشرين مليون شخص يعانون انعدام
الامن الغذائي وان اكثر من سته ملايين
مواطن سودانيه على بعد خطوه واحده من
المجاعه وشدد جمال على ضروره توفير مسارات
امنه لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه لملايين
المتضررين الذين يستحيل الوصول اليهم بسبب
صعوبات الامنيه
حاليا في ما يزيد عن عشرين مليون شخص
بيعانوا من انعدام الامن الغذائي وفي اكثر
من 6 ملايين شخص على بعد خطوه واحده من
المجاعه برنامج الاغذيه العالمي كان
بيحاول في الفتره السابقه من شهرين خمسه
ولما بعده وقدر يوصل لحوالي 2 مليون شخص
في ولايات مختلفه داخل السودان ولكن للاسف
توجد بعض المناطق اللي هي يستحيل الوصول
اليها مع الصعوبات الامنيه
وعدم التساهل من الاطراف
ويستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه مشاهدينا
وفي العناوين
اخراج احياء في درنه بعد سته ايام على
كارثه السيول والصحه العالميه تقدر عدد
المفقودين بتسعه الاف
السلطات المحليه تقرر اخلاء المناطق
المتضرره من درنا ونقيب الاطباء يحذر في
تصريحات للجزيره من احتمال الوصول الى
مرحله الوباء بسبب انتشار الجهد
وفي المغرب السلطات تعلن تمكنها من فتح
جميع الطرق الرئيسيه في اقليم تارودانت
فرق الانقاذ توسع عملياتها في الاماكن
المعزوله باقليم الحوز وبدو تفعيل خطه دعم
المتضررين
المعارك والعنيفه تتجدد وسط الخرطوم قصف
واشتباكات في محيط القياده العامه وقرب
سلاح المهندسين الجيش يسلم صليب الاحمر 30
طفلا كانوا يقاتلون مع قوات الدعم السريع
ووزير الصحه يقول للجزيره ان كل
المستشفيات الرئيسيه في الخرطوم ودافور
خرجت عن الخدمه
[موسيقى]
نبدا من تداعيات السيول في ليبيا
بدل ما تحصي درن الليبيه خسائر بعد
الكارثه التي المت بها جراء السيول تتواصل
جهود البحث عن المفقودين الذين قدرتهم
منظمه الصحه العالميه بتسعه الاف
واعلن وزير الصحافه الحكومه المكلفه من
البرلمان عثمان عبد الجليل ارتفاع عدد
الضحايا في مناطق شرق ليبيا الى ثلاثه
الاف ومئتين 252 قتيلا وما تصاعد اعداد
القتلى والمفقودين واتجاه فرق الاغاثه الى
عزل مناطق في درنه واخلاء اخرى ارتفعت
وتيره المناشدات طلبا لمزيد من فرق
الانقاذ والاليات والمعدات والخدمات
وقد تداول نشطاء على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي مقطعا مصورا لاخراج عائله من
تحت انقراض منزل هدمته السيول في مدينه
درنه وتظهر الصور مشاركه فرق اغاثه دوليه
ومتطوعين ليبيين في عمليه الانقاذ
كما تداول ناشطون صورا تظهر محاولات فريق
اغاثه اسباني التواصل مع احد العالقين تحت
الركان في مدينه درنه شرق ليبيا وتظهر
الصور الصعوبات التي يواجهها فريق الانقاذ
ومحاولات البحث عن اي اشارات لمعرفه مكانه
تحت الان بالله عليكم
يا عباد الله لو تسمع في حر في ايدك بس
يا عبد الله
حرك ايدك بس خربش
[موسيقى]
الجزيره محمد البقالي ومن طرابلس مراسل
الجزيره احمد خليفه ونبدا معك محمد
البقالي من درنه حول اي جديد يتعلق بتلك
العمليات المستمره عمليات الانقاذ الاغاثه
رفع الانقاض وايضا عمليات الايواء
حسن الواضح ان عمليات الانقاذ ليست سهله
على الاطلاق وليست يسيره والصور التي
شاهدناها قبل قليل تظهر ذلك العمليه تتطلب
اولا التقنيات متطوره للكشف عن وجود احياء
تحت الانقاض ثم بعد ذلك محاوله التواصل مع
هؤلاء الاحياء طبعا هناك طريقتين اما ان
اعتماد التقنيات او اعتماد ايضا الكلاب
المدربه التي يمكن ان ترشد المنقذين الى
اماكن الاماكن التقريبيه دعني اقول حسن
لوجوده هؤلاء الاحياء المفترضين ولكن بعد
ذلك تبدا عمليه اخرى ليست سهله على
الاطلاق من اجل تحديد المكان الدقيق
لهؤلاء
الناجين او الاحياء ومن ثم الحفر بعد ذلك
واخراجهم دون التسبب في اي انهيار قد يودي
بحياتهم وبالتالي فالعمليه كما نسمعها هي
معقده في الحقيقه جدا وهذا ما يفسر بطء
هذه العمليه
وصعوبتها وايضا
بالاضافه الى مساله امتداد المسافات او
التي
تتم خلالها هذه العمليات بالنظر الى حجم
الكارثه الكارثه كبيره ومست مناطق واسعه
ليس لم تكن محدوده في المكان في حي واحد
او في منطقه واحده هي ممتده على امتداد
مدينه دارنا باستثناء بعض طبعا بدرجات
متفاوته ولكن باستثناء بعض الاجزاء فان
معظم الاحياء تاثرت بدرجات متفاوته وهذا
ما يجعل مهمه عناصر الانقاذ ضعيفه ويمكن
ان اقول في الحقيقه ان الذي يدفع عناصر
الانقاذ الان الى مواصله اعمالهم هو تلك
الاشارات
وما يمكن ان نصفه بالانباء
الصره بين الحين بين الفينه والاخرى عندما
يتمكن عندما يتمكنون من اخراج احد الناجين
ولكن هذا الامر بصراحه بدات تتراجعوا
الامل فيه بالنظر الى بعد اسبوع تقريبا من
من عمليات من من نعم هذا ما يتعلق بعمليات
الانقاذ محاوله
انقاذ من يمكن انقاذه تحت الانقاذ ان كانت
هناك كان هناك احياء لكن
برز تحد جديد الموضوع البيئي الخوف من
انتشار او بيئه مساله مياه الشرب التي
هناك تحذير من ان يتم استعمال الابار او
المياه الجوفيه كيف يتدبر الناس امورهم في
ضوء هذه المخاوف
الحقيقه يمكن ان نقول ان مدينه درنا الان
هي مدينه
غير صالحه للحياه في هذه المرحله على
الاقل غير صالحه للحياه بالنظر عندما يتم
اصدار تحذيرات بشان الماء الصالح للشرب
فماذا تبقى في المدينه الناس معظمهم
يحرصون الان على شرب المياه المعبئه ولكن
هذا الامر قد لا يتوفر للجميع والامور في
الحقيقه يمكن ان نقول ان الاشارات
والتحذيرات تشير الى تدهور الوضع بين بعد
كل يوم وخلال الايام الثلاثه المقبله اذا
لم يتم تحقيق تحسن واضح في موضوع استخراج
الجثث وفي موضوع
ما يمكن ان نصفه بعمليه تعقيم المدينه
وتجنب الامراض الساريه التي يمكن ان تنتشر
في مثل هذه الحالات وخاصه منها واخطرها
ربما هو مرض الكوليرا بالاضافه الى الحصبه
وداء السلك كل هذه الامراض هي على لائحه
الامراض التي ترتبط بهذا الن ميناء
الكوارث خلال الايام الثلاثه المقبله اذا
لم يتم تجاوز هذا الخطر فان الموضوع فعلا
سيكون مثيرا للقلق اكثر مما هو عليه من
الان وسيكون منظرا باحتمالات حدوث كارثه
اخرى تنضاف الى كارثه الزلزال وطبعا عفوا
كارثه الفيضان وكارثه الفيضان هي في حد
ذاتها كارثه غير مسبوقه وهنا يمكن كل
المسؤولين الامميين على سبيل المثال او
منظمات الاغاثه او الجميع الذين زاروا هذه
المدينه والذين عرفوا فيما سبق كوارث
يقولون انها كارثه غير مسبوقه ونادره
الحدود الان المدينه بالفعل هي مدينه
اصبحت مهدده باحتمال اقول احتمال لانه لا
داعي للحديث بمصطلحات كبيره قد تثير الرعب
والفزع في نفوس الناس ولكن هذه الاحتمالات
هي وارده وسواء السلطات المجتمع ومنظمات
الاغاثه والناس يستعملون معها على انها
جديه شكرا لك محمد البقالي حدثتنا من درنه
وننتقل الى طرابلس مع احمد خليفه تابعت
احمد مؤتمرا صحفيا رسميا في العاصمه
الليبيه حول
ما يجري في درنه وتحذيرات ايضا ضعنا في
صوره تلك المعلومات
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي الذي عقد في العاصمه
طرابلس اليوم حسن تحدثت فيه او تحدث فيه
الفريق الحكومي التابع لحكومه الوحده
الوطنيه تحدثت فيه وزيره العدل عن
الاجراءات المتعلقه باداره الازمه وتحدث
فيه ايضا وزير البيئه عن اداره الازمه
ولعل ابرز ما ذكره وزير البيئه هو انه حذر
من تلوث مياه الشرب في المدينه وحذر من
كارثه بيئيه في المدينه وطلب اهالي درنه
بالا
يجعلوا اطفالهم يشرب يشربون المياه من
الابار الجوفيه بل يشربونها من المياه
الجاهزه والمعبئه خصيصا لذلك عدا ذلك كانت
معلومات المؤتمر الصحفيه مؤتمرات
بشكل عادي جدا تتحدث عن مجهودات حكوميه
لمؤسسات عامله في دارنا هذه المجهودات
الحكوميه حسن تترافق معها مجهودات اهليه
من اهالي العاصمه طرابلس على سبيل المثال
حيث اقف الان في منطقه الظهره بمركز
العاصمه وهي منطقه تاريخيه بالعاصمه هؤلاء
الشباب الذين تراهم خلفي يقومون بجمع
التبرعات لاهالي درنه هذه التبرعات هم
الان انتهوا عملهم هذا اليوم
واكدوا لي منذ قليل عندما تحدثت معهم ان
هذه الحمله مستمره لايام لم يحددوا اجلا
مسما لكنهم قالوا نحن مستمرون ما دامت
الازمه مستمره في درنه وسنرسل الشاحنه تلو
الاخرى وسنرسل القافله تلوى الاخرى واكدوا
لنا ان هناك شاحنه تاهبت اليوم الى مدينه
درنه وتوجهت الى هناك وهذه الشاحنه الاخرى
الان يقومون بتعبئتها بالمواد الاغاثيه
وبجمع التبرعات المواد الاغاثيه والغذائيه
والدوائيه والملابس
والمياه دعما لاهالي درنه هذا الموقع في
العاصمه طرابلس حسن ليس هو الاول من نوعه
وليس هو الوحيد ايضا هناك عده مواقع في
العاصمه طرابلس هناك هبه من الاهالي في
العاصمه طرابلس يوم امس على سبيل المثال
التقينا احد الشباب في احدى الحملات قال
نحن مستعدون ان نقلع ملابسنا
ليرتديها اهالي درنه ويحموا بها انفسهم
شكرا لك احمد خليفه مراسله الجزيره من
طرابلس
وتتركز عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه في مناطق
عديده من مدينه درنه صعوبات لوجستيه جراء
تضرر الطرق والبنيه التحتيه نتعرف على
ملامح المشهد على الارض في هذا التقرير
ملامح الفاجعه لم تكتمل بعد ذلك ابرز
انطباع مع انقضاء نحو اسبوع منذ كارثه
فيضان درنه دعا مدير عام المركز الوطني
لمكافحه الامراض حيدر السائح الى تقسيم
المدينه الى ثلاث مناطق متضرره وهشه وامنه
بهدف تحسين التعامل مع تداعيات الكارثه
واغاثه المتضررين
الشطر الغربي من المدينه هو الاكثر تضررا
وتتركز عمليات الانقاذ والاغاثه في مناطق
عديده ابرزها وسط المدينه والمغار
والجبيله وبمنصور على الساحل الشرقي
للمدينه المنكوبه روت مصادر بالهلال
الاحمر للجزيره ان فرق انقاذ من الغواصين
كشفت عن سيارات غارقه بعائلاتها جرفتها
مياه الفيضان ويوم الجمعه تقول المصادر
انما بين 500 الى 600 جثه كنتشلت من البحر
في الشاطئ الغربي اغلبهم من الاطفال وتحت
البحر وفق المصادر عينها عمارات بالكامل ج
يقول رئيس هيئه البحث والتعرف على
المفقودين للجزيره انه قد انتشرت جثه كانت
على مسافه 120 مترا داخل البحر تشكو فرق
الانقاذ من معوقات منها صعوبه الحركه بسبب
اكوام الوحل التي طمرت بنايات بكاملها ومن
صعوبه حركه الافراد والمعدات بسبب تلك
الاوحال الزلقه ويشكون ايضا من قله مواد
التعقيم بالنظر لاعداد الجثث الهائله
كان نائب رئيس المجلس المحلي بدرنه قد صرح
للجزيره بشان احتمالات اخلاء كلي او جزئي
للسكان بالتحديد توقع اخلاء حي الجبيله
والمغار وما تبقى من سكان وسط المدينه
مؤكدا نزوح اعداد كبيره باتجاه مناطق باب
تبرق والفتائح والساحل الشرقي وغيرها في
نفس السياق تحدثت منظمه الصحه العالميه عن
نزوح نحو 35 الف شخص جراء الكارثه
[موسيقى]
قال المن تحديث باسم جهاز الاسعاف
والطوارئ في ليبيا اسامه علي ان اولويات
المرحله الراهنه تتركز على الاسراع في حصر
العدد الفعلي للضحايا والمفقودين وتحديد
الجنسياتهم
ما يحتاج الاسراع في هو حصر عدد الضحايا
الفعلي او الرقم الفعلي لعدد الضحايا
فهناك الكثير من المكالمات عن مفقودين
لم يسالون عنهم ايضا حصر الجنسيات التي
توفيت بشكل جيد
حتى نتمكن من ايفاء كافه الشروط في هذا
المجال لا تنسى ان هناك من مصريين الجنسيه
واخواننا في مصر من سوريا من السودان من
فيجب اعاده يجب النظر في هذه النقطه ايضا
وليس النظر في الضحايا بشكل عشوائي فقط
وقال النائب العام الليبي صديق الصهور
للجزيره انه تم وضع خطه بالتعاون مع
وزارتي الداخليه والصحه لتحديد جثث الضحيه
والتعرف على هوياتهم
في مدينه
الداخليه الليبيه الصحه ورئيس الحكومه وضع
خطه
الاحداث في العمل بحيث انها تم التكليف
لجنه الاستبدال من وزاره الداخليه
مكتب النائب العام
تقوم بفتح هذا
المفقودين لاثبات المنقودين وادراج
العمليه
معنا من طرابلس حليمه ابراهيم وزيره العدل
في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه مرحبا بك
السيده حليمه سابدا من حيث انتهى النائب
العام بالحديث عن موضوع الجثث قبل ان
ننتقل الى التحقيقات او تكليف النائب
العام بالتحقيق بالنسبه لهذه الجثث قانونا
عليكم السلام
بالنسبه لهذه الجثث يعني قانونا كيف سيتم
التعامل
معها في مراحل لاحقه ستكون ربما هناك
اشكالات قانونيه مع عدم التعرف عليها ومع
دفنها بشكل جماعي وغير ذلك
سيدي حليمه تسمعينني
يبدو ان السيد
حليمه ابراهيم وزيره العدل في حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه لا تسمعنا بشكل جيد ربما
نعود اليها لدى اصلاح هذا الخلل المتحدث
باسم وزاره الداخليه في الحكومه المكلفه
من البرلمان طالق طالق الخراز قال في
مقابله مع الجزيره انه لا يمكن حصر اعداد
الضحايا والمفقودين واضاف ان عمليات
الاخلاء ستقتصر على المناطق التي تضررت
بشكل مباشر في دارنا
لا اعتقد اننا سنخرج كل اهل مدينه برلمان
من مناطق التي تضرر داخل مدينه برلما يعرف
في وسط البلاد والمنطقه القديمه هي
المناطق التي تضررت ضرر المباشر ونسبه
الدمار في 100% حددت النطاقها وكم
باغلاقها بدوريات امنيه داخل مدينه درنه
لمنع كل من ليس له علاقه بالعمل داخلها
البعثات او الفرق الانقراض الدوليه
والمحليه وكذلك من هم بالعمل سواء كان
الصليب الاحمر وغيرهم من سيارات الاسعاف
ودوائر التابعه لوزاره الصحه في مدينه
برما ان تدخل وان اكون باجراءات اخرى
تدابير واقرائيه احترازيه حتى لسلامتهم
وصحتهم داخل المدينه
نعود الى
ضيفتنا من طرابلس حليمه ابراهيم وزيره
العدل في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه سيده حليمه
كنت سالتك ان كانت هناك ايه اشكال اشكالات
قانونيه فيما يتعلق بوضع الجثث بالتعرف
عليها
بموضوع دفنها بشكل جماعي
شكرا لكم السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
احييكم جميعا
بدايه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه
والسلام على اشرف الانبياء والمرسلين
سيدنا محمد
نعزي انفسنا وكل الشعب الليبي في هذا
المصاب
نسال الله ان يتقبل من مات من الشهداء وان
يجبر مصاب مصاب الاحياء وان يعوضهم خيرا
وان يؤلف بين قلوبنا ويصلح ذات بيننا وان
يجمعنا على الحق
الحمد لله كثيرا نشكر الله ونحمده رغم
المصاب الجلل ما اود قوله ان وزاره العدل
في حكومه الوحده الوطنيه منذ حدوث هذه
الكارثه الطبيعيه السيول والفيضانات
بمناطق
شرق ليبيا مناطق الجبل الاخضر كدرنا وسوسه
وكذلك
البيضه وشحات
وتاكنس وكل المناطق
المتضرره اصدرنا قرارا عن طريق مركز
البحوث والخبره القضائيه ووحده الطب
الشرعي التابعه لوزاره العدل بتحرك فرق من
الطب الشرعي وفني
التشريح وكذلك من مركز المعلومات والتوثيق
التابع لوزاره العدل الان نقول لكم لا
توجد اي اشكاليات قانونيه وما يقال من
مقابر جماعيه هي ان دفنت فانها تكريم
لمن قضوا نحبهم ولكن ليس لمجهولي الهويه
مجهولي الهويه
اشتغلنا وقسمنا العمل في عده اماكن وعده
مربعات واخذ العينات وفق المعايير
والبروتوكولات في هذا الشان ونوهنا عنه في
اعلان سابق في صفحاتنا في الوزاره كانت
هناك ثلاث مراكز من بينها مستشفى الهريش
في نفس المنطقه وكذلك مقبره الظهر الاحمر
ومقبره الفتاح ومناطق اخرى تؤخذ فيها هذه
العينات ثم يقومون بترقيمها وكذلك ترقيم
الجثث ودفنها وفق الخرائط المتبعه
وهذا كله
لبحث عينات الخاصه بالحمض النووي الدين
وللتعرف ذويهم عليهم الان انشانا قاعده
بيانات خاصه بهذا الشان بالتعاون مع مركز
المعلومات والتوثيق الفريق الموجود هناك
كذلك التابع لوزاره
وتم انشاء هذه القاعده وفي صدد الاعلان عن
رابط
للمواطنين كل من فقد احد من ذويه لاخذ
العينه بكل سهوله وبتسهيل عليهم والاعلان
عن اماكن مخصصه لهم
فيما يتعلق بالتحقيق تكليف النائب العام
البدء بالتحقيق
بملابسات
انهيار السدين في دارنا ما هي الحيثيات
التي دفعتهم الى اتخاذ هذا القرار
والمضي بالتحقيق ومع من واي فتره زمنيه
هذا نوه عنه السيد العام هذه التحقيقات
لا نستطيع ان نقول ما ان كان هناك سبب
الانهيار السد او السدين او نقول هناك
ولكن نحن ما نعمل عليه الان في وزاره
العدل هو وفق
لوسائل علميه وكذلك
لفرقه متخصصه
ما نوهت عنه هو ان الدين الدين تعرفون انه
يتسم بعمل خاص وكذلك عمل منظم
ويضمن حقوق
المواطنين فيما بعد من حقوق شرعيه وكذلك
فرائض شرعيه وان وجد جبر ضرر وتعرف
المواطنين على ذويهم المفق ودين وهو كما
تعلمون عمل اختصاص وطني سيادي بامتياز
ليس لي وزاره العدل علاقه
بمساله
التحقيق او تكليف النائب العام بالتحقيق
بسبب انهيار هذين السردين في درنه
هناك خطوات اراها الان تسبق التحقيق وهو
ما يقوم به كل نشكرهم من هذا
الصدد كل فرق كل فرق الانقاذ سواء
الدوليه او المحليه او الدول الجاره
والشقيقه والصديقه وما يقومون به من عمل
لتفادي حصول او حصول اي اضرار ما ترتبت
عليه هذه الفيضانات سواء صحيه او بيئيه
تضر بالمواطنين في المستقبل سواء القريب
او البعيد كذلك اخذ العينات
وانتشال الجثث التحقيقات ان كان هناك
التحقيقات سيقوم بها
بالتاكيد النيابه العامه
وستقوم بذلك ان
وجد اي سبب لها
شكرا لك حليمه ابراهيم وزيره العدل في
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه من طراب
قال نقيب الاطباء في ليبيا محمد الغروج ان
هناك مخاوف من مرحله ثانيه قد تصل حد
انتشار الوباء بسبب تحلل الجثث التي لا
تزال تحت الانقاض او منتشره في مدينه درنه
واكد الغوش في مقابله مع الجزيره ان لجنه
الازمه في وزاره الصحه تكثف جهودها لتقديم
الرعايه الصحيه للمتضررين وان الاولويه
تتمثل في انتشال الجثث كما اكد الحاجه
الملحه الى وجود فرق للدعم النفسي
من المرحله الثانيه بتمنى من وزاره الصحه
ومؤسسات الدوليه لدعم هذا الموضوع في قصه
ان قد نصل الى الى قدر الله الى موضوع
الوباء النتيجه الاتحاد
اعطاكم الله الحفاظ الحيوانات تعتبر درنه
من من المدن المنتجه لهذه الاغلبك هذه
الحيوانات
في هذا الاثار ايضا زي ما قلت لحضرتك
موضوع الدعم النفسي اعتقد حيكون تحدي كبير
للسلطات الصحيه لوزاره الصحه
من جهه قال مدير برنامج الطوارئ بالمكتب
الاقليميه لمنظمه الصحه العالميه ريتشارد
برينان ان هناك خطرا حقيقيا لتفشل الاوبئه
والامراض في درنه وان هناك حاجه الى فرق
متخصصه للمساهمه في جهود الاغاثه فيها
واضاف في مقابلات مع الجزيره ان عدد قتل
السيول بدرنه تجاوز 4000 وتجاوز عدد
المفقودين تسعه الاف
ريق ما يقلقنا بشكل اساسي هو توفير
الرعايه الصحيه للناجين خصوصا من المصابين
بالكسور والجروح تدمير المنشاه الصحيه كان
كبيرا ونحتاج الى ان نجعل هذه العيادات
والمستشفيات تعمل مره ثانيه بالتالي
ارسلنا فرق طبيه للطوارئ ووزعنا نحو 20
طنا من المعدات الصحيه ومعدات الطوارئ كي
نضمن اعاده عمل هذه المنشات الامر الاخر
هو منع تفشي او بيئه والامراض شبكه المياه
متوقفه وهناك ثلاثه الاف شخص خسر منازلهم
وقد يتجمعون في مناطق مزدحمه وبالتالي
هناك خطر حقيقي لتفشل او بيئه والامراض
كالاسهال واصابه الجهاز التنفسي وفقر الدم
لهذا فان اتخاذ اجراءات لسيطره على تفشي
الامراض والاوبئه وتوفير المياه الصالحه
للشرب من الاولويات
من درنا معنى سالم النعاس مسؤوله التواصل
والاعلام في الهلال الاحمر فرع درنا سيد
سالم مرحبا بك الى اي مرحله وصلت
اعمالكم فيما يتعلق بالانقاذ والاغاثه
الان في دارنا
السلام جميعا عليكم السلام الحقيقه جهود
لا تزال مبذوله جوده مستمره الى هذه
اللحظه من اعمال الانتشار ومن عمل دراسه
ومنقذين يعني منذ مده ساعتين تم امر يعني
شخصين او ثلاثه اشخاص
والحمد لله كانوا يعني على قيد الحياه
نعمل لا يزال موجود بالله عز وجل
في دوله انحاء مدينه دوله ليبيا من جميع
فروع الهلال
من الجهود دوليه الاحمر
التونسيه لان الاحمر الجزائري الاسباني
تركي الايطالي يعني صراحه مجهودات لا زالت
الى هذه اللحظه حتى يعني ساعات الصبح يعني
ان تتحدث عن نظام دوريات الانتشار الجثث
الذي لم يتوقف الى هذه اللحظه العدد لا
يستطيع احد التنبؤ به سواء يعني كان
10,000 يعني نتحدث عن اعداد هائله انت لا
انت لا تتخيلها يعني يعني
نقول لك معلومه يعني قبر واحد كان دفن به
500 شخص
رايته فيعني الامر ماساوي الامر كارثي
نسال الله السلامه
وربي يحفظ الناس
من دوله ليبيا يعني
بدون تخصيص يعني تخيل انت يعني كل مدن
ليبيا لدينا في دارنا كل المدرب ليبيا
لدينا في دارنا يعني اشخاص متطوعين اشخاص
مدنيين
الصعوبات سيد سالم
الصعوبات التحديات التي تواجهنا في اثناء
عملكم كاهلال احمد
هلال الاحمر يعني انت تتحدث عن يعني عن
مباني كبيره يعني تحت تحت الارض يعني نسفت
فالامر يعني يتطلب وقت وجهد بوقت كبير
يعني وقت كبير لكي
تتعدد احصائيه الامر يتطلب عن عن وقت كبير
وجهد كبير يعني
للامانه يعني كل شيء متوفر كل شيء يعني
متوفر
يعني حديث يعني
سلم النعاس بندر رسول الاعلام والتواصل في
الهلال الاحمر فرع درنه شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى المغرب والمشهد بعد يوم ثامن على
كارثه الزلزال
[موسيقى]
تتواصل عمليات البحث عن ناجين وانتشال جثث
الضحايا بعد مضي اكثر من اسبوع على وقوع
الزلزال كما تركز على الهيئاته لغافيه
جهودها على ايواء المنكوبين وعلاج الجرحى
وقالت وزاره الصحه المغربيه ان عدد الجرحى
بلغ سته الاف
125 شخصا في حين اعلنت السلطات انها فتحت
جميع الطرق الرئيسيه التي تضررت من
الزلزال في اقليم تارودانت
ونشرت القوات المسلحه المغربيه مقطع فيديو
عبر منصه اكس قالت انه لانشاء فرقها مخيما
عسكريا متكاملا لواء المتضررين من الزلزال
في منطقه امزميز باقليم الحوز ويظهر
المقطع المصور اقامه المخيم العسكري
وتزويده بالخدمات الطبيه والمواد الغذائيه
وغيرها من المستلزمات الاساسيه
من مراكش ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره عمر
الحاج ليلخص لنا المشهد اليوم والمعلومات
على كل الاصعده فيما يتعلق بمناطق الزلزال
عمر
نعم حسن
حسب تجوالنا اليوم وحسبه حديثنا مع قوات
الوقايه المدنيه المغربيه فان هذه القوات
وهذه الاجهزه لم تضع حتى الان اي جدول
زمني لانهاء عمليات البحث عن ناجحه
محتمرين او
البدء بعمليات رفع الالقاب التي عاده ما
تعتبر كل المفقودين قد قضوا وبالتالي تبدا
بعمليه ازاله الركام بالاليات الثقيله
العقيد شكري هشام اليوم في
في جهاز الدفاع المدني او الوقايه المدنيه
المغربيه اكد لنا ان القوات ستعمل في
المدى المنظور على اعتبار ان يكون
المفقودين ناجون محتملون على هذا الاساس
سوف تواصل عملياتها باستخدام كل الوسائل
سواء عبر الطرق البريه او الوصول
بالمروحيات كما شاهدنا اليوم الى هذه
المناطق التي تقطعت قطعت الطرق اليها ولم
يبقى الا الطريق
ايضا على مستوى التبرعات
الصندوق 126 او الصندوق الخاص بضحايا
الزلزال اليوم وصلت التبرعات فيه من
المؤسسات الوطنيه السياديه وحتى من
المساهمين الشركات الخاصه والمواطنين
العاديين هنا في المملكه الى سته مليارات
درهم اي ما يعادل 600 مليون دولار من
المفترض ان يوزع منه المساعده لمره واحده
بقيمه 3000 دولار للعائلات المتضرره اضافه
الى مساعده ستكون بين تسعه الى 12 13 الف
دولار لاعاده ترميم 50 الف مسكن قدرتها
السلطات حتى الان بين من تهدم بشكل كامل
او بشكل كبير او بين من عاد غير
غير قابل للسكن مره اخرى عمليات الاغاثه
ان كنا سنتحدث عنها استمرت اليوم بوتيره
اعلى مقارنه بالايام الماضيه كونه اليوم
يوم السبت هو يوم عطله رسميه
والمواطنون الذين تفرقوا من اشغالهم
انطلقوا لارسال المساعدات ولكن التنظيم
الان باتا اكبر حسن بعد ان هابت السلطات
بكل المواطنين ان يفرغوا حمولاتهم من
المساعدات العينيه في في المخازن التي
اعدتها المؤسسات الوطنيه وعلى راسها مؤسسي
محمد الخامس والسادس اللي هي الاغاثه كذلك
الامر مستودعات التي اعدها المكتب الشريفه
الوطنيه
للفوسفات احد المساهمين الكبار بمناسبه في
هذه الحمله حمله التبرعات عمر الحاج من
مراكش شكرا جزيلا لك
ومن اقليم الحوز مركز الزلزال ينضم الينا
بينوا
مدير الاستراتيجيه في الاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر سيد
بنواه
هل لنا ان نعرف منك الاولويات التي
تضعونها كصليب احمر وهلال احمر في في
عملكم في مناطق الزلزال بعد مرور اكثر من
اسبوع على هذه الكارثه
الاولويات هي ضمان اننا نصل الى كل
الاشخاص الذين تاثروا بالزلزال الان انا
في منطقه في منطقه جبليه وانا ابعد عن
قريه اسمها هابات قمنا بادخال الخيم
والبطانيات
وايضا الاشخاص الذين لم يتلقوا المساعدات
لانهم يقعوا موجودين في اماكن بعيده
للغايه وقد استغرق من الوقت تقريبا سبع او
ثمان ساعات
لكي نصل الى هذه المنطقه هذه هي الاولويه
الجو بارد والجو يزداد بروده
خلال الاسابيع القادمه ايضا الجو بارد
ويزداد بروده ماذا عن اولئك الذين فقدوا
الماوى بالكامل
نعم نعم
تماما لهذا نحن نحاول ان نقوم بما نقوم به
باسرع وقت ممكن لان الجو بدا
بانخفاض درجات الحراره هنالك الكثير من
الاشخاص الذين خسروا بيوتهم بالتالي نحاول
ان نوفر لهم الخيم والبطانيات والملابس
الدافئه لكي يتمكنوا من ان يستقروا بشكل
من الاشكال هل لديكم الامكانيات
اللوجستيه اولا للوصول اليهم خصوصا
المناطق الجبليه النائيه وايضا الامكانات
الماديه
لتقديم
تتحدث عنه
نعم كما ذكرت قمنا
بتسليمي ثلاثي شاحنات من هذه التجهيزات
ولدينا خمسه عشر شاحنه كانت موجوده في
مراكش
والمشكله الان ان بعض القرى ما تزال
معزوله بشكل كامل ومنقطع بشكل كامل بسبب
انقطاع الطرق عندما انما مثلا عندما نصل
الى نهايه الطريق قد نحتاج الى السير لمده
ساعه هنالك مثلا بعض الامور التي يصعب
حملها مثلا خيمه قد تاوي خمسه اشخاص وزنها
ثقيل بالتالي الامر يتطلب وقتا لايصال كل
هذه المعدات من يحتاجها لكننا نعمل باقصى
جهدنا في الحاله التي
ذكرت كيف يتم ايصال المساعدات عندما تكون
الطرق مقطوعه كما كما
اعطيت مثالا قبل قليل
اثبتي لتلك القرى الطريقه الاولى للوصول
اليها
بعض الاحيان يتم استخدام الدراجات او
الحمير من اجل ايصال
التجهيزات اليهم بالتالي نحن نحاول سلطات
ايضا تحاولوا جهدها ويعرف
سكان المحاليل تماما كيفيه الوصول الى تلك
المناطق المناطق والقرى الصغيره البعيده
لكن
ليست عمليات التوزيع ليست كبيره بشكل ليست
كبيره لانه يصعب اصلا الوصول اليها
مدير الاستراتيجيه في الاتحاد الدولي
لجمعيات الصليب الاحمر والهلال الاحمر
شكرا جزيلا لك حدثتنا من اقليم الحوز مركز
الزلزال
في السودان نقل مراسل الجزيره عن ان معارك
عنيفه تجددت في الخرطوم في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني واوردت مصادر محليه
ان الجيش السوداني قصف بشكل متتالي من
مواقع الشماليه اندرمان مركزا للدعم
السريع بالعاصمه الخرطوم واقلت مصادر ان
اشتباكات عنيفه بالاسلحه الثقيله والخفيفه
سجلت حول الاحياء بمحيط سلاح المهندسين
جنوبي ام درمان هذا وقال الجيش انه سلم
صليب الاحمر ثلاثين طفلا كانوا يقاتلون مع
قوه الدعم السريع من جانب قال وزير الصحه
في مقابله مع الجزيره ان كل المستشفيات
الرئيسيه في الخرطوم ودارفور خرجت عن
الخدمه
لاكثر من 150 يوما ومشهد تصاعد دخان القصف
المتبادل بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
يتجدد بصوره شبه يوميه في فضاءات العاصمه
السودانيه بمدنها الثلاث وينتقل من موقع
لاخر
اعلنت مصادر الجيش يوم السبت ان محيط
قيادته العامه وسط الخرطوم شهد اشتباكات
ما عناصر الدعم التي حاولت الهجوم على مقر
القياده وان الجيش تصدى للهجوم وتقول
مصادر بالدعم السريع في جانب اخر ان
قواتهم قصفت سلاح المهندسين في ام درمان
والذي يعتبر من اهم مواقع المعارك الدائره
بين الجانبين منذ بدايات الصراع
وتتكشف الجوانب المؤسفه للقتال كل يوم
بمختلف انعكاساتها المباشره وغير المباشره
على الانسان ليس في مناطق القتال فقط بل
في كل اجزاء السودان
وزير الصحه السوداني قال للجزيره ان
النظام الصحي في كل المستشفيات الرئيسيه
والكبيره في ولايات الخرطوم ودارفور توقف
عن العمل عدد من الاشكالات التي واجهت
النظام الصحي مؤخرا تمثلت في
فقدان النظام الصحي لعدد من المستشفيات
الرئيسيه والكبيره في ولايه الخرطوم وفي
ولايات دارفور خاصه في الجنينه وفي نيالا
وفي شمال دارفور من ناحيه اخرى يكشف تسليم
الجيش عددا من القاصرين لممثل اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر قائلا انهم اسروا
اثناء قتالهم مع قوات الدعم السريع يكشف
عن وجه اخر من وجوه الصراع وانتهاكات
القوانين الدوليه التي تتم بين ثناياه
في هذه الاثناء تدور اسئله حائره كثيره
بكواليس ونتائج زيارات قائد الجيش ورئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان لست دول
المجاوره للسودان وغير مجاوره وكانت اخرها
يوغندا يوم السبت
يتطاول امد الصراع اذا ويعترف الجميع
بتداعياته المدمره ليس على السودان فقط بل
وباتره السلبي على المنطقه ولا تبدو على
الافقي اي بوادر تشير لقرب نهايته وقد
تعثرت مختلف المبادرات الاقليميه والدوليه
التي طرحت نفسها حتى الان
[موسيقى]
من جانبها قلت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان
الاجراء الاخير بشان سحب اعتماد مفتشي
الوكاله المكلفين بانشطه التحقق في ايران
هو قرار سيادي يستند للقرارات الدوليه
واتفاقيه الضمانات الشامله واكدت دعوتها
وكاله الطاقه الذريه للتعامل بحياديه
وتعاون الايجابي وفق الاتفاقيات الموقعه
وتامت الخارجيه الايرانيه الدول الاوروبيه
23 بانها تحاول استغلال الوكاله لاغراض
سياسيه رغم تعاون ايران وقالت على الدول
الغربيه سماح للوكاله القيامه بعملها
التقني وباحياديه وحذرت من اي استغلال
سياسي لها
ينضم الينا من مدينه ليدز في انجلترا
دكتور علم صالح استاذ دراسات ايران والشرق
الاوسط في الجامعه الوطنيه الاستراليه
دكتور علم مرحبا بك بماذا تفسر هذا القرار
الايراني بحق الوكاله الدوليه ومفتشيها
للطاقه الذريه
معاهده حظر
النشر النووي تسمح لاي دوله ومنها ايران
كاضو في المعاهده بان تطرد او تسحب اعتماد
اي من المفتشين اينما وارادت او شات فهذا
امر حصل قبل هذا
بين ايران والوكاله الذريه قبل هذا كذا
مرات فاذا ليس امرا جديدا
ولكن التوقيت هام جدا التوقيت جاءت بسبب
اولا ان بعض الشهر يوم 18 من الشهر القادم
العقوبات العسكريه ضد ايران تلغى
تلقائيا
وسمعنا من البريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا
بانهم لا لا
يلتزم بهذه بهذا الامر اي الغاء العقوبات
العسكريه وانهم يستمرون بالضغط
للعقبات العسكريه ضد ايران فاذا ايران
طردت ثلاث من المفتشين اليوم من ذوي
الجنسيه فرنسيه والمانيه لان لم يكن هنالك
مفتشين بريطين في ايران اساسا
النقطه الثانيه الهامه ان ايران تريد ان
تسقط على وكاله الذريه وكاله دوليه للطاقه
الذريه
التي تدعم من قبل الغرب حرب بالنسبه لكي
تكسب اي مكاسب مكاسب اقتصاديه في المستقبل
خاصه
للارصده المجمده الايرانيه في البنوك
الاجنبيه ثالثا ان توقيتها جاءت بعد سنه
من الاحتجاجات
العام في ايران فاذا ايران ترسل رساله
للغرب انهم لا يدعمون الاحتجاجات ان حصل
اليوم طيب لكن السؤال عن رده الفعل يعني
هل سيكون هناك رد فعل غربي ذلك
خصوصا ان الموضوع ايضا جاء في
خضم الحديث عن
تبادل سجناء بين الولايات المتحده وايران
وكان هناك قوه فتحت في جدار العلاقه بشكل
او باخر يعني كيف يمكن ان نفهم هذا الجو
الامر لا
تحصل هنالك اي توتر كبير بين الطرفان ولكن
هي طماطل سياسي بين الطرفان لكي يكسب
اكثر امتيازات او مكاسب
فلذلك ايران تعرف ان الغرب ليست مهتمه
لاحياء الاتفاق النووي في 2015 خاصه بسبب
تقرب الانتخابات الامريكيه فلذلك ليست لدى
ايران اوراق مساومه او ضغط على الغرب الا
من خلال نشاطاتها النوويه فلذلك تحاول ان
ان تقلق توتر لكي تكسب بعض المكاسب من قبل
القرض لان الغرب كما يبدو لم لم يكونوا
مهتمين في في الرجوع او للرجوع
للاتفاق النووي ولا ننسى ان الاتفاق
النووي تسمح لايران ايضا
ان اذا الطرف الاخر انتهكت التزاماتها
تسمح لايران بان ايضا يعني تعلق جزء او كل
من التزاماتها اذا شاءت
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور علم صالح استاذ
دراسات ايران والشرق الاوسط في الجامعه
الوطنيه الاستراليه حدثنا من مدينه ليدز
في انجلترا
التقى النقيب ابراهيم التراوري رئيس
المجلس العسكري الحاكم في بوركينا فاسو
وفدا عسكريا روسيا في العاصمه يوم السبت
وذكرت هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون في بوركينا
فاسو ان هذا اللقاء ياتي ضمن الجهود
الراميه لتفعيل الالتزامات التي تعهد بها
البلدان خلال قمه سام بطرسبرج الاخيره
لاسيما في المجال العسكري
واعلنت كل من مال والنيجر وبوركينا فاسو
توقيع اتفاقيه للدفاع المشترك تؤكد ان اي
مساس بالسياده الوطنيه لاحدى هذه الدول
يعتبر اعتداء على الاخرى
اي مساس بالسياده الاقليميه لطرف او اكثر
من الاطراف الموقعه على هذا الميثاق يعتبر
اعتداء على الاطراف الاخرى ويلزم جميع
الاطراف بتقديم المساعده والعون بما في
ذلك استخدام القوه العسكريه لضمان الامن
في الفضاء الذي يشمله هذا التحالف
من يمي مراسل الجزيره بابا ولد حرمه
ينضموا الينا الان بابا اهميه هذه
الاتفاقيه والى اي مدى ربما تدفع الاطراف
التي
تهدد بتدخل عسكري بمراجعه حساباتها
نعم حسن بالتحديد لا تندرج في هذا الاطار
في اطار تجسيدي وتعزيزي وتاكيدي هذا
التحالف في الذي بدات ملامحه تظهر منذ
اللحظه الاولى التي هددت فيها دولي
الاكواس بالتدخل العسكري في النيجر لاعاده
الرئيس محمد بازوهم الى سده السلطه كانت
هناك هذه الزيارات كانت هناك هذه اللقاءات
وكان هناك هذا البيانو المشترك الذي اعقب
قيمته التي لوحت فيها بتداخلها العسكري
هذا البيان والمشترك بين كل من مالي
بوركينا فاسو واكد هذا البيان قبل اكثر من
شهر ونصف شهر من الان على ان اي تدخل
عسكري للاكواس في النيجر سيعتبر بمثابه
اعلان حرب على البلدين واكدت
انهما لن تقف مكتبتين امام التدخل العسكري
المحتمدي للاكواز في النيجر اذا اتفاقها
مثقوليبتوكه
او تحالف دوليه الساحله الذي اعل هو اليوم
بين هذه الدول ثلاث مالي وبوركينا فاسو
والنيجر هو تاكيد لنقل انه صياغه قانونيه
لهذا البياني الذي كانت
اصدرت اصدرته قبل نحو شهر ونصف شهر من
الان يؤكد ميثاقو جرما او تحالف دولي
الساحل الذي وقعت هذه البلدان الثلاثه على
ان على ضروره احتراميه سيادتي الوطنيه
وسلامه الاقليميه لكل الدول ويؤكد في
مادته السادسه على ان اي تدخل عسكري اي
اعتداء اي مساس بالوحده الاقليميه
وبالتراب لاي من هذه البلدان يعتبر بمثابه
اعلان حرب وانه يجب على الدول الثلاث
التدخل مباشره وان عليها واجبه التدخل
لحمايه اي من اي من هذه البلدان التي قد
تتعرض للتدخل العسكري الحديد بالتحديد
الى النيجر وما تعيشه منذ اكثر من شهر
ونصف شهر على وقع هذا الانقلاب العسكري
وطبعا هذه البلدان الثلاثه تعيش كلها تحت
مجالس تحت حكم مجالس عسكريه وصلت الى
السلطه عن طريق انقلابات خلال السنوات
الثلاث الماضيه
الجزيره من نيامي شكرا لك
طلب متظاهرون تجمعوا امام القاعده
العسكريه الفرنسيه في مطار نيام طلب فرنسا
بسحب قوتها من النيجر والامتثال لقرار
المجلس العسكري انهاء اتفاقيات التعاون
الدفاعي بين البلدين ردد المتظاهرون
وتفاتم لفرنسا ولوجودها العسكري
والدبلوماسي في النيجر كما طالبوا السفيره
الفرنسيه بالرحيل وتعيش نيامي على واقع
مظاهرات رافضه للنفذ الفرنسي للتدخل
العسكري المحتمل لدول الاكواس وتنظم هذه
المظاهرات حركات شبابيه داعمه لما يطلق
على نفسه المجلس الوطني لحمايه الوطن الذي
يحكم البلاد منذ السادس والعشرين من تموز
يوليو الماضي اثرا انقلاب اطاح بالرئيس
المدني محمد بازو
[موسيقى]